[Musik]
hallo zu sammeln heute gibt es das
beliebteste subway subway dem subway
belag die mit chicken teriyaki super
easy zubereitet keine exotischen zutaten
und ich fange auch direkt an ihr findet
übrigens alle ganz genauen mengenangaben
unten in der video beschreibung ich habe
gestern zum beispiel das harte brot
gemacht davor hatte ich auch das ressort
egal ob am 8
mit genau tun und ihr könnt euch einfach
aussuchen wie ihr das letztendlich dann
kombiniert ich habe jetzt hier
hähnchenbrust habe ich schon mal sehr
sehr kleine stückchen geschnitten also
vorarbeiten habe ich hier schon
geleistet da gebe ich jetzt salz und
pfeffer dazu nicht zu viel salz aber ihr
seht ihr auch die genauen mengenangaben
unten weil da kommt er gleich musst du
ja soße dazu und sojasauce an sich ist
ja schon seit ich verfahre unbedingt
frische nehmen ein riesenunterschied und
das verhör zu kurz und gibt das dann
zusammen mit neutralem öl ich nehme
heute sonnenblumenöl wenn meine fahne
und dann brate ich das nur ganz kurz an
[Musik]
den teambus wird jetzt insgesamt circa
viel jugend gebraten müssen wirklich
keine stücke die werden schnell gar und
zigarren später auch noch in der soße
und nach drei minuten also in den
letzten minute quasi gehen wir
irgendwann mit dazu das schild ihr am
besten mit einem löffel und danach hab
ich's feinde hat meinem wiegemesser und
das jetzt noch mit dazu knoblauch auch
schon mit dazugeben und dann wie gesagt
für eine minute lang mit brat mitdünsten
tapezierer stufe 6 von 9 und danach
kommen die weiteren zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
und als nächstes sojasauce mit dazugeben
und außerdem noch apfelessig wieso
nämlich apfelessig also im original
terry a team kommt eigentlich mir ihn
mit ramires kreis essig seien wir mal
ehrlich wer hat reis es sich zufällig zu
hause oder braucht es immer wieder ich
nicht daher nämlich apfelessig den
naturtrüben passt meiner meinung nach am
besten und jetzt gebe ich noch braun zu
kann mit dazu der karamellisiert schön
und er ist auch super super wichtig
falls sie keinen druck gehabt nimmt gern
weißen oder nimmt honig das geht auch
also einmal mit dazugeben und jetzt
lassen wir das köcheln und zwar so lange
bis uns die seligkeit gefällt also dass
dix gleich ein
und das mache ich jetzt auch nicht mit
geschlossenem deckel also schön ständig
rühren und dann ein blicken lassen
[Musik]
dort sieht heftig lecker aus hoffentlich
auch mit mich reinlegen
ich weiß nicht wieso aber ich glaube es
ist auch fast fertig also ich geb dir
noch eine minute
dass sie so lecker aus und ich habe auch
schon probiert leute das haut mich
richtig um das haut mich richtig und ich
glaube dass man das auch jetzt in bolls
integrieren kann oder einfach in so ein
tag oder auf den salat was auch immer
das ist wirklich ein rezept dass er
vielseitig anwenden können wir machen
natürlich ein sub traums das zeige ich
euch welche im anschluss hier nochmal
die kurze info das ist jetzt bei mir 78
minuten lang köcheln durfte und so ist
es jetzt perfekt ich hole jetzt alle
anderen zutaten für mainz ab und dann
das du entscheiden was drauf kommt bis
gleich sonst schneide ich erst mal
meinen hand basiert auf und da gehen wir
dann natürlich schicken terrier
getroffen haben sie überlegt du in der
zwischenzeit was für toppings du
möchtest danke
[Musik]
guckt euch bitte diese schönheit an
ganz ehrlich viel zu schade zum essen
wenn ich nicht so einen riesenhunger
hätte dann würde ich mir das einfach
irgendwo die betriebe stellen
ich finds echt richtig hübsch ja und was
mir gerade eingefallen ist was dazu auch
noch passen könnte ist unsere suite
onion soße das rezept dazu ist schon
online
das wird jetzt endlich richtig gut
passen aber ganz ehrlich ich hab hunger
ich habe keine lust mehr jung ist zu
machen ich will jetzt einfach nur noch
essen kann so wie sieht's aus test zu
zweit allein
okay das ganze geheimnis meinte ratlos
ist ehrlicherweise ein bisschen dunkler
als the subway aber das ist einmal die
terrier klose ist ja auch nicht in der
fabrik hergestellt sondern zu hause doch
ein bisschen mehr wie soja sauce braucht
man auch für den geschmack sowohl das
wird gerade sage jedem fall wirtschaft
ist 1 1 ab ohne irgendwas zu kleckern zu
essen der ist nicht normal
der ist einfach nicht normal okay wir
probieren es schmeckt total würzig
richtig krass wird man braucht keine
extra man braucht keine extra soße mehr
der arglose also ich finde das schon
mega es auch richtig lecker jeweiligen
bisschen beschreiben so gesagt immer ob
ich mit mega lecker und die dinge bei
apple selbst alle mega weg aber es ist
eine frage schmerzt zu salzig schmeckt
würzig schmeckt scharf ja also lecker
was sollen wir prinzipiell ist es lecker
einfach und schnell und das war auch
echt einfach und echt schnell und
einfach echt nett und keine kann
zutaten moment wo ich muss jetzt halb
asien bereisen um die zu kaufen also das
rezept leute titel garantie
ausgesprochen macht es unbedingt nach
ich werde nicht von subway gesponsert
aber ich empfehle euch meine rezepte
wirklich sie sehr
na ja und nein
welche inspirieren wir ja auch die leute
jetzt nach sapporo praxis abzugehen
also ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen ich
möchte jetzt einfach nicht richtig
hunger und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal euren key
[Musik]